wie ist die erde in ihrem inneren
beschaffen ist dort im erdmantel der
versunkene kontinent pangea verborgen
deutschen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern ist jetzt die
sensationelle entdeckung gelungen
die fachleute haben eine bisher
unbekannte region des erdmantels
aufgespürt die unter der äußersten
erdkruste beginnt und bis 2900 kilometer
tief ins erdinnere reicht höchst
wahrscheinlich überreste von pangea dem
letzten superkontinent der erdgeschichte
kriegs und science fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierendes sein süden
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen die
mittlere schale im erd- inneren der erde
wird als erdmantel bezeichnet sie reicht
bis zur unglaublichen 2900 kilometer
tief ins erdinnere und liegt zwischen
dem erdkern und der erdkruste im
erdmantel kann es bis zu 3500 grad heiß
werden die meisten der wenigen
erkenntnisse über das innenleben unserer
erde konnten durch komplizierte
verfahren wie geophysikalischen
berechnungen oder aber der analyse von
tief im erdmantel liegenden diamanten
gemacht werden doch die geheimnisse die
jetzt ein forschungsteam lüften konnte
kamen auf andere art und weise ans
tageslicht die fachleute bedienten sich
dabei nämlich direkt an gesteinsproben
und zwar von den bermuda inseln im
westlichen atlantik denn diese
inselgruppe befindet sich auf der spitze
eines rund 4500 meter hohen vulkans der
bereits vor rund 30 millionen jahren
verloschen ist dieses gestein ist aus
magma entstanden und wirklich eine
geologische besonderheit konkret
analysierte das münsteraner
forschungsteam vulkanisches gestein das
schon in den 70er jahren aus einem 760
meter tiefen bohrloch auf bermuda heraus
befördert wurde und so erkannten die
fachleute dass die erde unter bermuda
aus zwei verschiedenen vulkanischen
gesteinsarten bestehen deren
geochemische analyse war eine echte
premiere und so gelang dann auch die
sensationelle entdeckung eine neue
region des erdmantels die bislang völlig
unbekannt war
sie weist eine besondere atom
zusammensetzung auf unter anderem
besteht sie aus kohlenstoff wasser
anderen flüchtigen stoffen und blei
welches durch radio
diesen zerfall entstanden ist eine
wirklich einzigartige zusammensetzung
denn laut der expertin und expertin
weist sie den höchsten anteil an
bestimmten blei isotopen auf der jemals
auf einer ozeanischen insel gemessen
wurde
diese atomsorten ermöglichen es den
fachleuten zu verstehen wie sich der
erdmantel zusammensetzt denn die
chemische zusammensetzung in einem
vulkan ist gleichzusetzen mit der
erdmantel region aus der die gesteins
schmelzen stammen laut der
forschungsgruppe stammt dieses mantel
reeser von gesteinsplatten die in der
sogenannten übergangszone in einem
bereich zwischen 410 und 660 kilometern
tiefe gespeichert sind und nicht nur das
höchstwahrscheinlich handelt es sich
hierbei um überbleibsel des letzten
superkontinents der erdgeschichte pangea
alle landmassen der erde waren in diesem
superkontinent vor ungefähr 250
millionen jahren zusammengefasst und von
einem einzigen mehr an thalassa genannt
umgeben die verbindende landmasse
existierte wohl bis vor 150 milliarden
so etwa dass diese neue erkenntnis
tatsächlich durch die analyse von
gesteinsproben gewonnen werden konnte
ist wirklich der hammer und macht
hoffnung auf weitere sensationelle
entdeckung in diesem zusammenhang dazu
der forscher esteban gar selbst die
entwicklung in bermuda zeigen dass wir
weiter inseln unter wasser berge und
andere vulkanische regionen im
atlantischen ozean untersuchen sollten
um unser verständnis der geochemischen
evolution der erde zu verbessern
die aktuelle studie enthüllt aber noch
mehr geheimnisse über das innere unseres
planeten beispielsweise wie kohlenstoff
und wasser im erdmantel gespeichert sind
das forschungsteam ist optimistisch das
bermuda es auch ermöglichen könnte den
kohlenstoffkreislauf tief im erdinneren
auf die spur zu kommen zudem könnte so
auch die antwort auf die ungelöste frage
gegeben werden wie viel kohlenstoff sich
überhaupt in der gesamten erde befindet
dazu studienleiterin sarah maza unsere
studie zeigt dass unser
verständnis von der zusammensetzung des
erdmann es immer noch unvollständig ist
obwohl wir ihn seit fast einem
jahrhundert untersucht haben
wenn es dazu mehr infos gibt dann
erfahrt ihr sie natürlich hier wenn ihr
hier darauf klickt da geht es zu
telegramm und nur da könnt ihr nämlich
klicks um so abonnieren dass er
garantiert kein video verpasst und ihr
bekommt die videos dort nicht nur früher
sondern es gibt diskussionsgruppen ihr
könnt safe themenvorschläge machen und
vor allem bin ich dabei
zudem gehört telegramm nicht zur
facebook datenkrake und man muss seine
telefonnummer auch nicht preisgeben wir
sehen uns also auf telegramm bis dann
bleibt